we want to test the hypothesis that more
than 30% of US households have internet
access with a significance level of 5%
we collect a sample of 150 households
and find that 57 have access so to do
our hypothesis test let's just establish
our null hypothesis and our alternative
hypothesis so our null hypothesis is
that the hypothesis is not correct our
null hypothesis is that less than that
the proportion of US households that
have internet access is less than or
equal to 30% and our alternative
hypothesis is what our hypothesis
actually is is that the proportion is
greater than 30% we see it over here we
want to test the hypothesis that more
than 30% of US households have internet
access that's that right here this is
what we're testing we're testing the
alternative hypothesis and the way we're
going to do it is we're going to assume
a p-value based on the null hypothesis
we're going to assume a proportion based
on the null hypothesis for the
population and given that assumption
what is the probability that 57 what is
the probability that 57 out of 150 of
our samples actually have actually have
internet access and if that probability
is less than 5% if that probability is
less than 5% if it's less than our
significance level then we're going to
reject the null hypothesis in favor of
the alternative one so let's think about
this a little bit so we're going to
start off assuming we're going to assume
assume the null hypothesis is true and
in that assumption we're going to have
to pick a a population proportion or a
population mean we know that for
Bernoulli distributions are the same
thing and what I'm going to do is I'm
going to pick a proportion so high that
so that it maximizes the probability of
getting this over here and we actually
don't even know what that number is and
actually so that we can think about a
little more intelligent let's just find
out what our sample portion even is we
had 57 people out of 150 having internet
access or 57 households out of 150 so
our
simple proportion is 0.38 so let me
write that over here our sample
proportion our sample proportion is
equal to 0.38 so when we when we assume
our null hypothesis to be true we're
going to assume we're going to assume a
proportion a population proportion we're
going to assume a population proportion
that maximizes the probability that we
get this over here so the highest
population proportion that's within our
null hypothesis that will maximize the
probability of getting this is actually
if we are right at 30% so if we say our
population proportion we're going to
assume this is true this is our null
hypothesis we're going to assume that it
is 0.3 or 30% and I want you to
understand that if we said you know we
29% would have been in our null
hypothesis 28% that would have been in a
null hypothesis but for 29 or 28% the
probability of getting this would have
been even lower so it wouldn't have been
as strong of a test if we take the
maximum if we take the maximum
proportion that still satisfies our null
hypothesis we're maximizing the
probability that we get this so that
number is still low if it's still less
than 5% we can feel pretty good about
the alternative hypothesis so just to
refresh ourselves we're going to assume
a population proportion of 0.3 and if we
just think about the distribution
sometimes it's helpful to draw these
things so I will draw it so this is what
the population distribution looks like
based on our assumption based on this
assumption right over here our
population distribution has point or
maybe I should write 30 percent 30
percent have internet access and I'll
just signify that with a 1 and then the
rest don't have internet access the rest
the rest don't have internet access 70
percent do not have internet access
this is just a Bernoulli distribution we
know that the mean over here is going to
be the same thing as the proportion that
has Internet access so the mean over
here the mean over here is going to be
the mean is going to be 0.3 same thing
as 30 percent this is the population
mean and maybe I should write it this
way the mean assumed
the mean assuming our null hypothesis
the population mean assuming our null
hypothesis is zero point three and then
the population standard deviation let me
write this over here in yellow the
population standard deviation assuming
our null hypothesis assuming our null
hypothesis and we've seen this when we
first learned about Bernoulli
distributions it is going to be the
square root it is going to be the square
root of the property of the percentage
of the population that has internet
access so 0.3 0.3 times the proportion
of the population that does not have
internet access times 0.7 right over
here so this would be the square root
this is the square root of 0.2 1 and we
could deal with this later using our
calculator now with that out of the way
we want to figure out the probability
for in our sample the probability of
getting a sample proportion that has
0.38 so let's look at the let's look at
the distribution of sample proportions
so you could literally look at every
combination of getting 150 households
from this and you would actually get a
Bernoulli distributed a distribution and
we've also seen this before you would
actually get a binomial distribution
where you'd get a bunch of bars you
would get a bunch of bars like that but
if your n is suitably large and in
particular in particular and this is
kind of the test for it the test if n
times P if n times P and in this case
we're saying P is 30% if n times P is
greater than 5 and n times 1 minus P is
greater than 5 you can assume you can
assume that the the the distribution of
the sample proportion of the sample
proportion distribution is going to be
normal so if you looked at all of the
different ways you could sample 150
households from this population you get
all of these bars but since our n is
pretty big it's 150 150 times 0.3 is
obviously greater than 5 150 times 0.7
is also greater than 5 you can
approximate that with a normal
distribution so let me do that
so you can approximate it with a normal
distribution so this is this is a normal
distribution right over there now the
mean of the distribution of the
proportion data that we're assuming is a
normal distribution is going to be and
remember working under the context that
the null hypothesis is true so this mean
is going to be this mean right here so
the mean of our of our sample
proportions the mean of our sample
proportions is going to be the same
thing as our population mean so this is
going to be 0.3 same value as that and
the standard deviation this comes
straight from the central limit theorem
so the standard deviation of our of our
of our sample proportions the standard
deviation is going to be the square root
it's going to be the square root let me
put this way it's going to be our
population standard deviation but the
standard deviation we're assuming with
our null hypothesis divided by the
square root of the number of samples we
have and in this case we have 150
samples it's going to be 150 samples and
we can calculate this this value on top
we just figured out is the square root
of 0.2 1 so this is the square root of
0.2 1 over the square root of 150 over
the square root of 150 and I can get the
calculator out to calculate this so this
is so let me just I'll just do it the
way I wrote it
square root of point 2 1
and I'm going to divide that so that
whatever answer is I'm going to divide
that by the square root square root of
150 so it's a point 0 3 7 so we figured
out the standard deviation here of our
of or the distribution of our sample
proportions is going to be let me write
this down I'll scroll over to the right
a little bit it is zero point zero three
seven I think I'm falling off the screen
a little bit so we'll just lay zero
point zero three seven now to figure out
the problem
to figure out the probability of having
a sample proportion of 0.38 we just have
to figure out how many standard
deviations that is away from our mean or
essentially calculate AZ to z statistic
for our sample because the Z statistic
or z-score is really just how many
standard deviations you are away from
the mean and then figure out whether the
probability of getting that Z statistic
is more or less than 5% so let's figure
out how many standard deviations we are
away from the mean so just to remind
ourselves this the sample proportion we
got we can view is just a sample from
this distribution of all of the possible
sample proportions so how many standard
deviations away from the mean is this so
if we take our sample proportion
subtract from that the mean of the
distribution of sample proportions and
divide it by the standard deviation of
the distribution of the sample
proportions we get we get 0.38 0.38
minus 0.3 minus 0.3 all of that over
this value which we just figured out was
zero point zero three seven so what does
that give us so the numerator over here
the new morover over the numerator over
here is just zero point zero eight the
denominator is zero point zero three
seven so let's figure this out so our
numerator is 0.08 divided by this last
number right here which is the point
zero three seven
so the second answer and we get two
point one I'll just round it to two
point one four standard deviations so
this is equal to this right here this
right here is equal to two point one
four standard deviations or we could say
that our Z statistic right we could call
this our z-score or Z statistic the
number of standard deviations we are
away from our mean is two point one four
where two point one four and two B but
to be exact we're two point one four
standard deviations above the mean we're
going to care about a one-tailed
distribution
now is the probability of getting this
more or less than 5% if it's less than
5% we're going to reject the null
hypothesis in favor of our alternative
so how do we think about that well we
want let's think about just a normalized
normal distribution or maybe you could
call it the Z distribution if you want
if you look at a normal distribution a
completely normalized normal
distribution it's mean is at zero its
mean is at zero and essentially each of
these values are essentially z-scores
because if you are one a value of 1
literally means you're one standard
deviation away from this mean over here
so we need to find a critical Z value we
need to find a critical Z value right
over here let me call that a critical
critical Z we could even say is the
critical z-score or critical Z value so
that the probability of getting a Z
value higher than that is 5% so that
this whole area right here is 5% and
that's because that's what our
significance level is anything that has
a lower than 5% chance of occurring for
us will be validation to reject our null
hypothesis or another way of thinking
about if that area is 5% this whole area
this whole area right over here is 95%
and once again this is a one tailed test
because we only care about values
greater than this Z values greater than
that will make us reject the null
hypothesis and to figure out this
critical Z value we can literally just
go to a Z table and we say okay what Z
value has in it the probability of
getting a Z value less than that is 95%
and that's exactly the number that this
gives us the cumulative probability of
getting a value less than that and so if
we just scan this we're looking for 95%
we haven't point nine four nine five we
have point nine five oh five so I'll go
with this just to get make sure we're a
little bit closer so this Z value and
the Z value here is one point six and
the next digit is five one point six
five so this critical Z value is equal
to one point six five so the probability
of getting a ZV
you less than 1.65 on a or or even in a
completely normalized normal
distribution the probability of getting
a value less than one point six five or
in any normal distribution the
probability of being less than one point
six five standard deviations away from
the mean is going to be ninety five
percent so that's our critical Z value
now the Z value or the Z statistic for
our actual sample is two point one for
our actual Z value we got is two point
one four it's sitting all the way out
here someplace so the probability of
getting that was definitely less than
five percent and actually we could even
say what's the probability of getting
that or something or a more extreme
result and if you figured out this area
and you could actually figure it out by
looking at Z table you could figure out
the p value of this result but anyway
the whole exercise here is just to
figure out where if we're going to
reject the null hypothesis with a
significance level of 5% we can this is
a more extreme result than our critical
Z value so we can reject we can reject
the null hypothesis and in favor of our
alternative